okay so by now you should have seen
Avengers endgame if not sorry not sorry
spider-man is an end game so you will
have to hear about it here's everything
you need to know before you go see
spider-man far from home first let's
establish that this is a new spider-man
played by newcomer Tom Holland these
films are a departure from the one
starring Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield except for the origin story of
the superhero this new spider-man
franchise falls into place with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe with tentpole
films like Iron Man Thor and guardians
of the galaxy so let's take it back to
Captain America Civil War where
spider-man is first introduced into the
MCU cat captain big fan spider-man yeah
we'll talk about it later
just hey everyone good job Tony Stark or
Iron Man has been keeping tabs on the
teenager who's been web slinging around
New York for six months
Tony recruits him for his team as he
gears up for a feud against Captain
America
Tony updates his look giving him the
official spider-man costume we all know
and love they fly to Berlin and meet the
rest of the Avengers after helping out
Iron Man Black Panther war machine Black
Widow and vision spider-man returns home
to Queens New York they're going home
I'll call Amy you're done
yeah I'm not moving along to spiderman
homecoming peter parker is excited to be
an avenger after his experience in civil
war basically but Tony tells him he
isn't ready yet but I'm ready for more
than that now no you're not he takes on
an internship at Stark Industries but
it's really a cover so he can continue
his crime-fighting ways how do you do
this
anistar internship this is dr. Jeff
uh-huh
one night after preventing a robbery his
best friend Ned discovers Peter's been
moonlighting his spider-man can you spit
fennel can you summon a Gnomeo spiders
Liz a new love interest of Peters is the
daughter of the villain in this film
Adrian Toomes he's played by Michael
Keaton and his character turned criminal
after his company was destroyed by Tony
Stark
he goes by vulture because he can fly
using the Chitauri technology he
discovered and sells it on the black
market
spider-man was struggling to find his
confidence because iron man always came
to his rescue
but in the end defeats vulture after a
tough battle
fun fact pretty late in the films and
day--is revealed to be playing a pretty
chill version of the iconic Mary Jane
what are you hiding
Peter I'm just kidding out okay bye
Avengers infinity war
spider-man played a major role in trying
to defeat Thanos but sadly he was one of
the fifty percent of the population that
disappeared after the horses snap
but you should know by now he returns an
Avengers endgame he and half the
population returned after five years of
past he helps the Avengers defeat Thanos
and his crew but sadly his mentor iron
man dies after making the ultimate move
that keeps them all safe he's pretty
tough it was pretty tough because even
grown up with it with Robert playing
iron man and he's such an iconic
character everyone's looked up to him
spider-man far from home takes place in
the future Peter is struggling with the
new responsibilities of being the top
superhero now that Iron Man is gone
everywhere I go I see his face this is
the first time we get to see the
aftermath of endgame and what it's like
for New York and the rest of the world
post reversed snapped
what about Thor off world catch and burn
unavailable any new spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space it's
kind of like that that uncle or
grandfather is Chauncey when you're
gonna grow up take responsibility they
tell me you're the guy but they're not
join the two together
the world needs next Ironman you're
going to step up not now you know and
now you can go see spider-man far from
home July 2nd
[Music]